all the members and officers
to this our fourth uh virtual meeting of
the pandemic
overview and scrutiny committee and
can i remind members of as i always do
this meeting is being broadcast live
and will be available after the meeting
via the council's
youtube channel and can members
and officers please remember user raised
hand
feature mute your microphone when you're
not speaking
and if you're struggling with your
internet connection
i'm told that turning off your camera
may help but good luck to you if that
happens
um we have three main items tonight
the first substantive item is the
executive response
to the children and young people
scrutiny committee
task and finish group on send
and for the other two substantive
items we have executive members and
officers been asked to provide updates
to the committee some documents were
received in advance
and circulated along with the agenda i
hope that
everybody did receive those
i think they were quite comprehensive uh
package of information in in response to
some of the issues that we've raised
also just to let you know that
a report has been received today
regarding children
mental health services and it has been
received
quite late and it's but it is a report
that
you know we have asked for um but
because it's
it was only received today i thought it
was wrong
to just stick it on the agenda so um
i i agreed to put the item on the agenda
for
the next meeting which will be on the
19th
of august uh so
with that um introduction we'll go on to
the
agenda proper um and the first
item is attendances and apologies and
i've received
um notice
from councillor new council slater
and councillor shaw and i think there
was one other as well
council white and i think everybody else
is
is here um
i don't know whether anybody else has
got any apologies for
other members no um i've had apologies
uh councillor acton from um councillor
carter who would have liked to have been
in attendance and to support some of the
um
the the school's information but she's
unfortunately unable to attend
and and likewise with karen samples as
well
right thank you item two
is uh minutes of the meeting held on the
15th of june
and the first of july so there's two
sets of
minutes and these need to be approved as
a correct
record can we agree to those
i'm happy to move down yeah yeah
declarations of interest yeah so i'm
sorry sorry to break it i tried the
the hand so i tried to raise hand punch
i'm not sure if it worked
yes it does yes it does it's there now
anyway so yeah okay
just one small point on the minutes of
the first of july and she showed me not
being there and i was
all right can we correct that
alex it's on that
uh amendment to be made yeah thank you
so we're going to item three a stand
standing item declaration of interest
uh if anybody's got an interest can they
declare now uh councillor johnson
i work for traffic parents form which is
met
mentioned in one of the reports okay
thank you
any others no
okay we'll go on to questions now and
um a question has been received
from elizabeth stanley who is
um not present today but
um as she is not present the procedure
is for me to read out the question in
full
and um and i think we you know i think
we've got jill mcgregor
who is here the director and we have uh
counselor cut hands so um
if if you're unable to to to answer any
of
the
parts of the question then we can
actually
um uh give a a written response
to to any part that you're unsure of
um so i'll read it out
and here goes does there need to be a
more
granular focus in the plans given
given the um bame
students are disproportionately
represented in send
statistics and exclusions
and in brackets if 32 percent
of trafford school population is from
the bain community
does there need to be more detail
in terms of students ethnic background
and postcode so that limited resources
can be razor sharp on those students who
are more likely
to require targeted intervention and
support
other minority groups such as those
with english as an additional language
in care
and from gypsy traveler communities
young offenders may also benefit from
specific focus the plans are very
generic
does there need to be a focus on
families
who have not historically engaged well
with services and
a rethink of how and when
and where the engagement occurs
who is in control the vision and
ambitions
set out in the documents are quite
general and i'm not sure
how we will know things have improved or
changed
how will this be measured how will you
know it is working
is there enough health representation
on the partnership board do we have a
dmo
a stroke dco and
how will all this be communicated
throughout the children's workforce
so that they know what the expectations
are on them as partners with families
and how does the document link into the
jsna traffic together
local locality plan and the social care
children's improvement plan so it is a
long
uh question um we have several
several strands to it so i don't know
who's going to kick off on that
right councillor heinz thank you very
much
chair it is a long question and i will
kind of try to break it down if i can
into sections um i did
really want to thank elizabeth stanley
actually for
these questions which i do think are
incredibly
um important um and
you know it's it i think she's she's
right to um to
focus on those areas that she has done
so i am grateful
um for the the questions um
with regards kind of the the first
aspect of the
the question um which addresses the
um the more granular focus around
support really for
um being students um
with with scnd um i i i'll i'll kind of
answer that that part of the question
first um so the educational
psychology service um has developed a
race and trauma working group and
the purpose of this group is to
recognize how unconscious bias and
institutional forms of racism
will have an impact on children young
people and families
from vain communities and this group has
now met
twice um and has been tasked with the
following
and so they've been tasked with
developing an understanding
of how services can engage with children
and young people from vain communities
in a way that does not reinforce
inequalities and prejudice
with reevaluating types of assessments
that are used to understand the needs of
children
and young people from vain communities
and understanding those assessments
and that have cultural biases um
inherent
in them so i think that will hopefully
um address some of that kind of granular
detail that
um that is referred to and
that it will focus on um
research resources that can support
developing an
anti-racist um curriculum in schools
develop an explicitly anti-racist
service policy
and the development of an outcomes based
framework particularly
in the area of preparing for adulthood
which will enable us to generate
longitudinal data
um on how we can be assured that young
people
are achieving good outcomes as they move
into adulthood
and then um how we can you better
utilize really
data including um the morbidity rates
independent living statistics activity
and engagement measures
and employment data and so that we can
determine
what is working for children um as they
develop
into adulthood um
with regards the vision and ambitions
which have been set out in the um
task and finish response and
i think again that you know it is a a
fair question
um actually those ambitions and that are
in that report are actually
it is the kind of the the the high level
information and it doesn't give you kind
of what sits
underneath that so um underneath
kind of the ambitions um there are
actually you know detailed action plans
um and each of the um action plans
has its own task and finish group really
to make sure that
all of those ambitions um are undertaken
um and um
each are headed by relevant strategic
leads
and the detail plans are to be shared at
the next strategic
board which will take place um after the
summer
holidays and also it's important to say
and i think we you know we it is
um the first substantive item on
tonight's agenda
and but it is important just to kind of
reassure
um elizabeth really that you know this
is something that we are
very very focused on um and the
as an executive we are going to monitor
um
there is a an equality assurance
framework that's being built around the
whole
of the system um so albeit the the
ambitions are a kind of the
the titles there is a lot of work that
sits beneath all of those
um is there enough health representation
on the partnership board and do we have
a dmo or dco
and we do have a dco um in addition to
this
um there are health representatives um
including a
community pediatrician um they've been
on
the new assessment panel for the last
year um
we're working closely with the interim
dco
um over kind of covid and and health
commissioning um and there are regular
meetings
with um the ehc operational managers
across
education health and social care and
supporting operational decision making
as well as having that kind of that
quality assurance role
and in terms of how will all this be
communicated
throughout the children's workforce um
so that the workforce know what the
expectations are
of them um as uh partners
with families um you know again this is
an incredibly important area and it is
essential that all
who are involved in assessing and
supporting children
with send understand the expectations
um of the service really um and are
meeting those
requirements again as i was saying you
know we're going to have that
um quality assurance framework which is
currently
in draft form but is due to be um up and
running very soon
um there is a membership of the
communications and engagement
um group um which again is referenced
in the task and finish report which
which we'll we'll be talking about
but that group um you know it is
intended that they will enable all of
those plans to be
disseminated really across the service
but actually across the wider system and
the wider partnership
and so um
you know that there will be a a a key
strategic
focus on this area um and again it is
something that
um as an executive we will be monitoring
and
supporting um and how does um
this document link into the jsna traffic
together locality plan
and the social care children's
improvement plan
um well actually it the the send
um jsna is informed
by all of those documents um and you
know absolutely is informed by the
trafford
jsna um and the governance of
the send strategic board actually
sits um with the the startwell board
which is a board
that um that that i chair um and so
all of that is is fed upwards into the
start world board so there is that
governance structure
around that so i am hoping that that
does
offer some um reassurance that
we are absolutely um you know mindful of
all of those key areas that um
elizabeth as raised with us but you know
they are absolutely important questions
thank
you okay um
thanks very much for that so i think
that's a
quite a comprehensive response back
um and i i think that
uh elizabeth may be watching or will we
will tune in uh at a later time
um so so i think with that
um i don't know whether there's any
questions from any members but i don't
want to
linger too too much on this because
we've got a lot to to
to deal with okay
so thank you for that um
response uh we now move on to item five
which you did urgent business which i've
none i have not received any uh so we'll
we'll move quickly on to item six
uh which is the executive response
to the children and young people's
scrutiny committee report
on send um so i think it's again
over to you uh councillor hines
thank you very much chair um so
i'm not intending to speak um too much
to to the report because obviously
members will have had
a copy of the report and um i know that
i'm really conscious
that people will want to have some time
to ask some questions and i'm quite
happy
if people want to contact me outside of
this meeting you know if there's
anything that occurs to people
you know please do do that um
i would just like to apologize actually
for the amount of time that it's taken
to bring this back to
um the the scrutiny committee it was
presented
by the um children and young people
scrutiny committee in the task and
finish group
and it was presented back in september
to the executive
the response was initially ready by the
first february but
then we went into the new pandemic
arrangements and that's delayed
the response um but it's it's in no
means indicative
of how seriously that we do take um
that report um
so um i i just would also like to
to hugely thank everybody that was
involved in bringing that piece of task
and finished work
together um it it was a really detailed
report um and you know i know that a lot
of people were involved in bringing that
together so thank you
very much um
there have been some really important um
and significant
improvements which i would like to
acknowledge um actually because i think
it's important to do that
and there have been improvements around
performance and particularly
around the timeliness of um
our plans um which we are really pleased
to see
um but you know there are some areas of
um
significant improvements really that
that still
um needs to take place and there's a
whole
uh body of work really that is underway
to address
um you know all of those issues and i
think the report kind of
drills down into um
into all of that activity um i think
it's important to say that that activity
is being co-produced um
and that um that that parents
uh trafford parents forum um that young
people are being consulted um and that
um all of these steps are being taken
really to
to address the points that have been
raised i think understanding the
experiences of children
young people and families um is going to
be critical really in ensuring
that continuous improvement and and we
do very much welcome the initiatives
that
um that are wrapped around this to
support this
um including proposals for a pair
a parental walkthrough of the service
and a project to develop
an outcome-based framework for send
and which was launched through training
from the council of disabled children
and we're really eager to see the
implementation of the quality assurance
framework that i've just been talking
about
and and also to see ascend peer review
take place um the pandemic has
unfortunately impacted the embedding
of the inclusion charter in schools
which was launched earlier in the year
um but following the full reopening of
schools the aim will be to ensure that
every school in trafford
um is an inclusive school
and so the areas i think that you know
we are absolutely
focusing on and just to highlight some
of the areas that there are lots of
areas but for me
um i think that quality quality of
assessment and
quality of provision um is absolutely
critical um and as is
um as is the the kind of early
intervention
um and is um the kind of the
communication and engagement
um so the task and finish group have
requested
um further support to carry out some um
some further areas of work um
and you know as an executive we'd just
like to confirm
our support for this but with that i
think you know i'll just kind of
open it up to any questions but just to
caveat
um by opening it up to questions
unfortunately
uh karen samples couldn't be um here
with us
this evening um which um you know so
if there's anything technical that we
can't answer uh likewise with uh
councillor carter as well
so but we have myself and jill who will
hopefully be able to field
some of your questions thank you very
much for that
councillor hines um right open it up for
questions have we got any questions yeah
councillor thompson
thanks so much councillor thompson yeah
thank you
thank you councillor heinz
it's um i think we've very much welcomed
that we're not just looking at the
quantity we're looking at the quality of
ehc
plans uh going forwards
and i noticed that one of the strands of
that would be
to uh review sort of random a random
selection of the plans
so i've just got a question around how
would how do we ensure that
the selection of the plans will be
random
and representative of firm
of the plans that we issue and does the
task and finish group think that the
plan should be anonymized
or would it be better to get the parent
carer
um permission so that the plans could be
reviewed
reviewed in full given that the test and
finish group
probably um data controllers i would
think we would have to
review them with the the gdpr
rules um you know with guidance
kind of thing thank you
yes if i could am i okay to answer
um yeah yeah that that's brilliant so i
think my understanding
um is that the i think the request was
for a random sample of anonymized um
data um plans
and because i think you're absolutely
right to raise the gdpr
and i think that's what the request was
and i think what the service have said
is we're happy to facilitate the request
as long as it's compliant with gdpr
um i guess what we could do actually um
because i don't think the detail of that
i think what's happened is we have
uh the service have said yes i think you
know let's
let's make that happen so that um the
task and finish
members or members of the committee
actually can have that kind of assurance
around
looking at those plans um let's see how
we can facilitate that the detail of how
you do it
hasn't actually been worked out so
um perhaps what we could do is is um
take what you've suggested there
um i don't know perhaps if you you might
have been suggesting that as a parent
maybe a member of the the
uh trafford parents forum i'm not sure
so
but but i think what would be really
important is how we do it
is done in a way that is gdpr compliant
but a way that
perhaps traffic parents former are
comfortable with
as well but also that then meets that
requirement for
the members who are looking at this i
think from that assurance perspective
really
um again in terms of um the the
randomized nature
i suppose it would depend on
what it is that you know specifically
the
the um task and finish group wanted to
know
out of that so if for example they
wanted to know
something about um assessments for
you know children of a certain age or in
a certain locality
or from an ethnic background or
something like that
um then there are a couple of things
with that so
there is obviously um we need to make
sure
that if you're looking at a smaller
sample you can't then
identify who people are from that
and which is very important um but then
how you randomize
kind of the the the plans that you're
looking at as part of that is also
important so
i think to answer your question if in a
long-winded way
um the detail hasn't been worked out we
want to make sure that it
it it is compliant um but it also
answers the questions for for from
members
um so yeah we can do that in a way
that that kind of suits everybody but it
doesn't just answer the question
okay can i just bring uh counselor
denise weston
in because i think you wanted just to
make a comment and then uh
i know jill mcgregor wants to come in as
well
denise um originally
requested um or we would have been happy
with anonymized
um plans um as to the randomness
i think i'd quite like to see personally
a good plan
and a perhaps a poorer plan
as well um just to get
to be able to gauge i think we'd also
like to look at
um some plans are quite simple and
satisfy the needs of
the child and the parent some plans are
a lot more complex
um but i think what we'd really like to
see are the outcomes of these plans
as well so a bit bit of follow-up
information
to see how the plans have worked out and
and that would perhaps um require more
um working together with parents
um and obviously they would have to be
comfortable with that
and we would always try to maintain um
confidentiality as far as we could
yeah okay thanks gil
[Music]
thank you councillor acton thank you
councillor thompson and
weston um in terms of answering the
question
i think there's a number of facets to it
as councillor heinz has said
one is about what the service does
routinely in terms of quality assurance
framework and outcome measures
and i think what we're saying is there
is a clear commitment
to embedding that quality assurance
framework
of which both quantitative and
qualitative
outcome measures will be part and order
10 golf plans
by managers with responsibility has to
be a key routine activity
i think the other aspect from the task
and finish point
of view is well that might feel like the
service is marking its own homework
so what is the additional assurance that
we need to bring
into that set of arrangements and how
can we do that not just
in terms of the task and finish work but
on a multi-agency basis so as we can say
is that reasonable in terms of all the
health needs being met
is that reasonable in terms of the type
of provision
and actually what's the voice of the
child what's the voice of the parent
carer
in terms of that and actually working
through
what a genuine multi-agency partnership
engagement process can be
is slightly more complex than being able
to do it from
a service specific focus as part of our
routine work
and i think it's those aspects that we
are suggesting
probably need to be better worked
through and
done on a joint basis so there are
things like whether we could walk
through
somebody's plan and somebody's
experience on anonymized basis
whether we can do things like
conversational audits so speaking
to parents and carers who have gone
through the process
and saying what their feedback looks
like
so when we're saying that we have
started on our quality assurance
framework we've started on that journey
what we are saying quite openly is
there's a bit more to do
and there is learning from elsewhere
there is a real
commitment from the service to be able
to do that
and there are some if you like
additional complexities such as how do
you protect
the integrity and the confidentiality of
whoever's planet is
in terms of the randomized nature we do
have data we do have information and we
would be
suggesting that actually the selection
of which plans get audited or how that
happens is done from that
data perspective so we know how many
numbers of plans
we've got we've got case numbers
attached to them and that could be
randomly selected
and what i would be suggesting is that
we bring back
um we don't bring back our thoughts but
we continue to work those thoughts up
together
collectively and but certainly in terms
of the commitment
to actually start embedding our
internal audit process that's something
that we're well underway with
and i hope that answers some of the
questions that you had
thank you very much thank you are there
any
other questions um with regard to
the information that we've been sent uh
on the responses
um yeah yeah uh
count counselor karen barker thank you
chairman
it's just really continuing on um the
kind of um
assessment of plans and reviewing them i
mean can that not be
fed or are you thinking of feeding that
kind of activity into the annual review
because there is a natural point in
everybody's
ehcp particularly obviously for school
children where they are reviewed
annually
i mean if not more frequently but
certainly there is a very major annual
review and can you not i mean i know
that you could already come to those
meetings but
can your assessment of those actually be
uh
part of that because there's a lot of
learning to be done at that particular
point and you do get the voice of the
child as well thank you chairman
okay thank you and just to come
back in terms of that question um
in terms of the annual review clearly
the annual review needs to focus on
individual children and individual needs
and focus
in terms of have we done what we said
are those things still pertinent to
those individual children's needs and
what do we need to do
i think the quality assurance aspect is
a layer on top of that
so some of that is about how the overall
service is performing
what that looks like in terms of
collectively
so if we've done 100 plans in a period
of time
how many of those were appropriate how
many of those met those
children's needs and how many had
individual service provision
undoubtedly if through the review
process there were issues about the
quality or points of disagreement then
that clearly does need to be addressed
so i think it's a combination of things
but i wouldn't want to dilute the annual
review
being focused on individual children's
needs and what we needed to do for them
in terms of moving things forward
okay thank you um counselor jane dylan
hi thank you i'm just looking at section
2.5
um i just wondered if somebody could
talk us through
the parental applications just a bit
about
the grammar schools and the parental
anxiety around
year six to seven and in particular the
legal tests
the lower legal tests that seen an
increase in parental applications
thank you
and in terms of that counselor dylan i
haven't actually
got the ability to see the screen in
front of me in terms of the reports and
i'm working from home so i'm not 100
clear what the specifics are in terms of
that
and that is probably one of those areas
that i would like to make sure that i
give you the correct information
rather than say something that was
inaccurate
i don't know because councillor hines
you've obviously got the
the paperwork there if there's anything
you can um
point to in terms of it but apologies i
don't have the
the report in front of me because i'm
working from the flames
just locating it now
i mean there is no problem if you can't
get the answer uh today um
you know a written response will be fine
but if you
if you've got it yeah i i think
it may be one as well that um
because it's it it sounds quite specific
as well around
around schools it may be one that we
would want to get
karina's input and um and karen's input
as well
so i will do that and um come back
to um counselor dylan if that's okay
and i'm just i've got several screens
open at the moment some bitcoin
that's absolutely fine okay can i just
bring um
jane the curve in
yeah jane
jane the third sorry i was
trying to unmute myself um all right
okay
yeah so right fine and it was really
just to go back on the point around
um the anonymity of the uh report
because obviously this is these are
being reviewed from a qa
perspective to their quality assurance
and i think there is an issue there
around them being
anonymized because whether or not
there's actually any real purpose or
benefit that's to be served
by um having the details of the
individual
uh family or child in it incorporated in
it when it's reviewed for that purpose
um uh councillor hines quite right he
said we'll look at it but my instinct
would be that it's unlikely that we
would be uh looking to
remove uh the anonymity from those
reports but we will
we will consider it i suppose it might
be helpful if we would understand
better from uh council thompson's
perspective why
um it's felt that the pet from the
parents group perspective why they feel
that it might be
um important that those details are
still
available because i would say my
instinct would be that it would not be
necessary
yeah i i think obviously it's a
sensitive issue that has to be
dealt with very carefully uh and
i think everybody recognizes that it's
just how
how best we can actually um you know
achieve the objective that we all
want and uh you know if there needs to
be more work in in relation to that
that's very
fair enough uh councillor thompson you
just wanted to come back on
yeah just to make it clear that was just
my my
thoughts it wasn't from the parents
forums about the anonymizing
of the the plans yeah thanks
that's fine um
right so so i think um we with the
previous question
um we will get
a written response uh to to that
question
uh and sent to um councillor dylan i
think
if if um if all members
need it i think that's you know then
they can ask
for it as well okay
um is there any other questions in
relation to
um the the report um i i just have
one really and it is going back to the
quality assurance framework which i know
um you know it's still in development
stage but um
i i think the monitoring
of of that um scrutiny would be very
interested in the monitoring
of that um i i know that's not in the
paragraph that i've read that that
it would go to scrutiny um but i think
you know it ought to go to scrutiny
because i think that is something that
we
you know we would want to continue uh to
to
to monitor uh as we work through this
i don't think you'd have any problem
with that so i'm hoping he won't
yeah but jill oh sorry sorry
councillor denise weston uh had her hand
up first so i'm sorry about that
so yes thank you um just a quick
question
and i'm looking at section 3.1 um
i'm delighted to see that the timeliness
of issuing the plans has improved
significantly
um and we've now
got 76 being completed within 20 weeks
my concern is obviously um a lot of the
schools have been closed
we're coming up to the um annual summer
break for schools
are we in a position to deal with the
influx
really that we can expect in september
um is the system going to be
robust enough to cope um with any
additional referrals which i think we
will get
um once all the children return to
school
yeah i think good question jill are you
able to
uh i guess the answer to that will be
when we do see what that looks like so
what i can say
is that just like every other service
area
we have tried to maintain and sustain
business as usual processes
so we have still had our panel processes
in place we have
still been undertaking assessments where
we've been able to but clearly if
children have not been in school
then that has limited some of the scope
in terms of that
every service area has been planning
and continues to plan in terms of their
recovery plans
and for our children with additional
needs for our children who do have
ehcp plans that is no different really
and so we are thinking about the influx
we are continuing to work very closely
with trafford parents forum
i know that that's one of the areas from
that inclusion perspective
and how actually the pandemic has
actually helped cement and consolidate
some of those relationships
has been something that we absolutely
need to take the learning and continue
to
think about and embed as routine
practice
um and i think in terms of whether we
will sustain that good performance and
the question that counselor acton said
about
would we be comfortable and happy to
continue to report on a range of
performance measures
i think it's entirely appropriate that
that question is asked
and as you know we committed to making
sure that our performance indicators and
our reporting go
does go through the send board but
equally given that this has been such a
significant piece of work
from the scrutiny perspective we would
be more than willing to
report on an agreed frequency against um
our performance measures excellent
that's really good if there's no other
questions
um can i just thank profiters
and members of the executive um
for for the response is a comprehensive
response and i think
a lot of work has come into that and i
also obviously like to thank the
task and finish group as well for um
for putting their report to the
executive
right can we now move on to item
seven and this is um
health and adult social care and to
receive an update of the
position in trafford and um
to discuss the buddha's continued
response to
covered 9 19.
clearly this is a an important
subject um and i think we have um helena
ralph are you going to just do the short
presentation because i'm sure that
there's lots of questions that people
have
i know i have some so
[Music]
i think we've done a written report on
the questions from last
time so i'm going to just concentrate on
the covid
work at the moment because i'm sure
people are slightly alarmed by seeing
trafford
in tables that we don't like to see
traffic in yes
i would want to reassure you that our
numbers remain low
so it's um it's a question of this is
manageable but we do need
every we need to start thinking about
how we support our population to start
um behaving a little bit differently i'm
going to try and share my screen i don't
know if it'll work
but i'll just run through a presentation
for you if that's okay
um
[Music]
so can you see that
no no always always a joy
um let me try again
share screen and
no no
the joy of technology
would it be helpful if we asked some
questions because i think
shall i just i'll run through the
headlines for you and then
just the headlines and then you then the
questions because i think
well we'll see whether my things meet
your
questions so what's happened in trafford
over the last
week or so the last 10 days is we've
seen an increase steady
well a big increase in cases we were at
about three cases per
100 uh per day and that has stuck
at that for quite some weeks up and down
a little bit
but then from the um 18th
or so of um 17th 18th
of july we started seeing an increase in
the number of our
yeah our late teens early 20s population
testing positive and then
we had a sharp increase in the number of
people testing positive each day
on the 20th 21st 22nd 23rd
dropped down a little bit over the on
the 24th 25th
rising up again on monday um
and when i we only got the um
pillar two data the details of the data
at the beginning on tuesday last week
and when i started looking at the data i
realized that we were seeing a lot of
teenagers
and early twenties you know in that
figures and
over half of our of the new positive
cases
were in that younger younger age brand
um we did we had only a couple of cases
of people over 40 and
so it was very much concentrated in a
younger population
over the weekend we've seen the ratio of
the teenagers dropping out of the atom
but we're still seeing
slightly higher figures as i say
increased figures certainly compared to
the previous weeks
but it's now seeming to be
focusing more on i would say
people in their 30s and little children
we've got a few of those and we've got
quite a few cases of people in their 20s
30s and 40s coming through
i suspect the teenage issue the 17 and
18 year olds is probably linked to
perhaps some
um increased uh
physical uh increased activity among
that
age group increase social mixing and
possibly a couple of people becoming ill
and then
i i think probably what they've done is
they've told all of their friends
go and get a test and all of their
friends have gone off and got a test
um and hopefully that means that we will
now have contained that and we'll be
keeping a very very close
eye obviously i look at these figures
every day now i have this data
so that's where we're at our positivity
rate that means the number of people who
test positive
uh um for all compared to the number of
tests done
is now it's about three percent we were
at about one percent
the national average is one percent and
i want us to get down to one percent we
are testing a lot more people we're
doing very well with testing compared to
many other areas and we've had
additional testing sites available
um but there are there's an app i can
link you to that will show
um that you can look at yourselves and
so that you can see where we're up to
but in terms of the triggers we are
below the fifty
a thousand per hundred thousand fifty
cases per hundred thousand per week
we are below the five percent positive
rate that would be real causes for
concern
our actual numbers are a worry
particularly because we've gone
over the modeling numbers so we are
looking as if we are red
but that's based on national modelling
of where we should be
um and we where i
also think is of interest is just the
sheer spread of cases around the borough
we're not seeing the same pattern as
places like alderman rochdale
our demographics are very different from
oldham and rochdale but
i think what we're seeing is a lot of
people engaging in testing
and coming forward when they're
symptomatic and getting that test
and that may be why we're seeing so many
cases coming through so quickly
okay can i just be before i bring
anybody else in
um i i i just because
clearly there was a press release
yesterday um
which gave us figures um
and uh you know recognizing that been
quite a big
increase and and but but it kind of
played down
um you know the the the issue of it uh
and um and
the there are a number of people who
obviously saw the
uh covered 19 uk hot
we were in fifth place in that tracker
and that was a national you know um
assessment really uh yeah um where we
are and and
and i think people have
spoken to me about it um
and that they were quite worried about
it and
and we we don't seem to have triggered
much alarm
around the whole whole issue i know
geraldine
uh once wants to come in and i'll i'll
bring her in now
before uh because she probably like can
i just respond briefly to that so i
think
we we are because we've seen that sharp
increase but from a very low base
so a lot of the other places so we're in
the area we're we're in that top group
but we're not yet an area of concern
which is the
um bottom rung of that there's area of
concern
and then there's um intervention and
then there's
something else um so we are we are at
the bottom rung
of that i do not want to be in that
category at all none of us want us to be
there
but at the moment it is because we have
that sharp increase from three to four
to 16 17 cases a day our average cases a
day are now about 10 cases a day
that's more than we want to see but it's
nothing like where
lester bradford oldham or
um uh blackburn are
so rochdale has been so we are we are
in there because of that that rise we
have to get on top of this
but the other thing is that we are very
different the spread of our disease is
very different from
from those other areas and i i suspect
it is in
um particularly when i look at the age
groups affected i think it probably is
in people relaxing probably healthy
individuals relaxing
going out a bit more and we need to
really make sure that that population
doesn't if
um a that they start thinking a bit more
about the behavior
and b that we don't allow any spread
from that population
into perhaps their parents and
grandparents
so so it is about how we get that
messaging out to people
what we're not seeing fingers crossed
touching what etc we're
not seeing the spread in the care homes
and we're not seeing an increase in our
over 65 population
and i have to say yet yeah
um okay there's a number of people who
who want to come in and there's
geraldine you you you wanted to come in
then uh councillor
weston and councillor karen barker
uh councillor john lamb and councillor
linda so there's a lot who want to come
in
right geraldine i'll start start with
you uh
thanks chair and thanks ella for for the
um the detailed update
um i was just wondering about a little
bit in your reports in report
it says our exceedance report is now
rated red
now i think you've answered some of my
questions as you've been talking
so i'm guessing the exceedance report
from what you say is the projections
they've looked at the projections of
where we should be and we've gone beyond
that
so our results are worse than they
should be i was wondering is that
correct is that what the criteria
are and what are the criteria for that
becoming in the red zone
uh you know are we it seems to indicate
from what you're saying that we're not
particularly deep into the redstone
and and i was wondering how many other
councils are in that red zone either in
the northwest or around the country
okay yes and i'll ask question which
i'll come back to if you like because
it's slightly separate
okay so um yes the the exceedant
exceedance reports are based on modeling
of what where they expect people to be
along the trajectory of
ideally decline and they give you an
upper and a lower
they're called credibility intervals
rather than confidence intervals because
it's to do with modeling rather than
actual data and in trafford we have
um it's it's they looked at your so they
say oh well we expect you to have
x number of cases every day this is the
upper number this is the lower number
we were doing really well until
literally until
um about the oh i would say the
16th even of july we were pottering
along
underneath our blue line the lower line
and then we've shot up and we've
exceeded
almost every day since then i think
every day since then
so that's that's why we are red on that
indicator
um what you can do that indicator is an
order
indicator so leicester is now green on
that indicator because they're coming
down
but they still have far more cases than
we do so it is
it is a slightly artificial indicator
you would always look at it
alongside other local intelligence
um in terms of who else is read on that
indicator at the moment
i think off my top of my head i think
rochdale who've got the most cases i
think maybe amber
manchester's red sulfur's red circle's
red uh oldham's red
uh tame site i think isn't red but i
think wigan might be they've got tiny
numbers of cases so
i think it's now eight out of ten
boroughs in greater manchester i read on
that indicator
the north west overall is definitely
showing
the most areas of concern so blackburn
quite a lot of lancashire um obviously
we're not an area of concern but we're
we're on that top table along with
rochdale and oldham
so um there does seem to be a
something happening in the northwest but
i would say our
the pattern that say rochdale and oldham
and blackburn have seen
which is very concentrated in ethnic
minority populations living in deprived
inner city
multi-generational households that from
the data
i'm looking at for trafford does not
seem to be the case for us
okay thank you and if i may just come
back with my other question um it was
just about
um obviously we've seen an increase in
positive tests from young people
i'm wondering do we have the data say
we've had an increase in overall tests
from young people so do we have week by
week records
of who is tested by age group and if not
would that be something useful to have
we don't have it we are asking for it
all i guess is the total number of tests
which actually sometimes i have to work
backwards from some of the other data
sets so
i think at the group leaders meeting
there are a few questions asked and i've
now done a reply to all of that giving
and we'll we'll include that every every
week but we are doing well i would say
in great in trafford we've had we're
testing um
131 people per day per 100
000 of our population so last week we
tested over 2 thousand people
great all right thank you that's really
helpful okay
uh counselor denise weston
eleanor um i might be taking a quite
simplistic view of these
the figures um that you spoke about
um initially
for our young people uh teenagers being
tested positive um
seem to almost directly correlate to
the pubs reopening on the 4th of july um
and likewise um it concerns me that our
younger children
there's been an increase in that and
again a couple of weeks
um from i think our school's um
reopened on the 10th of july obviously
there'll be uh
people much more qualified than myself
to look at that but from just looking at
those figures
um my main concern is that there will be
a spike
um once we get our um 18 year olds going
off to university in september
and that all children are back in school
is that something
you would envisage yourself um
um i suspect so when i'm talking about
the teenagers i am talking about the 17
and 18 year olds and i suspect there was
some sort of
you know lots looking at the postcards
think knowing
what we know about how the fact that
friendship groups in trafford will
probably be a bit different from
friendship groups in boroughs that don't
have selective schooling and boys
schools and girls schools
young people in trafford travel more for
schools than many than
children in other boroughs so they'll
have friendship groups that are perhaps
more scattered around the boroughs
i suspect that um the though that
younger age group that sort of sixth
form and
university age group uh the lockdown
ended and they all went out and saw
their mates
um and you know they probably socially
distanced very nicely
before pint number one by pink number
four they probably weren't socially
distancing quite so nicely
um look at looking at the cases that are
coming forward i mean we've been doing a
lot of work with our schools and jill
um will uh i don't know if she's still
on the call but jill mcgregor will
certainly be able to
talk about that but we um we have been
doing a lot of work with the schools so
we do know when people are testing um
going for testing in schools and if
anyone tests positive we're not seeing
very much
many cases of outbreaks related to
schools there have been some children
but i don't think it's related so far it
doesn't look like it's
in the main related to school exposure
it's probably other exposure that then
um involves a school-aged child
and we are seeing as i say we're seeing
a lot more cases now of people in their
30s
late 20s and i suspect again that's and
with the ones in the late 30s again
there's small children involved
i'm not sure whether the whether it's
that the
children have been exposed through um
going to an early years setting i
suspect it's more that
the children have been exposed because
the parents have been exposed because
they've all been out more
they've been playing out more with their
friends they've been you know out and
about seeing people
so i think it is just my view at the
moment is
that it is about general social
interaction and people relaxing
and not taking it seriously and thinking
oh it's it's over
um and we'll get on with it and i think
we need to be getting some messaging out
fast and we are i've been i've done two
a men interview bbc
northwest interview today and um radio
manchester interview today
and the sunday mirror apparently
tomorrow so
um and the teenagers is going there
so so you're very busy um
i've got councillor barker next but
after that it's
uh councillors lamb blackburn and aidan
williams
and um joe mcgregor
so thank you chairman if if it's my turn
now thank you very much and appreciate
that and thank you to elena
for her report and i was quite shocked
when i saw the figures
and about the young people when i when i
when i first saw them and actually i did
a rethink and thought
i'm not that surprised at all because um
i do feel i mean
ellen wrote to us as counselors if we
were aware of anything that was going on
within our communities
and i certainly do feel knowing from my
own children and other young people and
their friends
there is definitely a feeling and a
belief in an attitude that um
young people are immune to it that if
they catch it they're not gonna get
symptoms
they're not going to become poorly and
and the number of deaths is obviously
falling which is wonderful so this kind
of feeds into the sensation that you
know things are over and
truly i do believe that we need to get
really
really strong messages out to our young
people in the in
the systems that really reach them well
that this is not over that it's a
serious
um condition as we all know and also
that
now we have to have evidence in trafford
that young people are actually becoming
symptomatic which i actually
find quite worrying as well as our
little ones you know that younger people
should become symptomatic particularly
given we know the serious
consequences even just having the
disease and surviving it can bring
so i do think it's really really
important i'm sure ellen as such as
she's doing a lot of messaging on it but
i think we really need to exploit any um
chinks we can
to reach um people in their late you
know late teens
early twenties thirties to to say look
this is serious for you as well it's not
just something that affects granny and
grandpa
and because i do believe that um our
young people think it's over
and uh they're acting as if nothing has
ever happened and that is obviously
quite concerning
so and i'm appreciative to elena and
working on that
but then um i would like to ask ellen a
couple of things first of all about
contact tracing for our teenagers i mean
how are we doing with that because
obviously it's going to be really
important we do contact trace
everyone they've been in touch with and
in terms of kind of isolating and
quarantining
how can we enforce that because that's
so difficult for young people i mean
particularly that
don't really believe in the whole thing
anyway many of them not all but
a number of them don't and then also
just as another thing about surveillance
and quarantine
and how are we or are we are we
developing a strategy or
are we just leaving it to national
responses for the moment about surveying
people who return to the borough from
spain
thank you okay so for the young people
in the contact racing obviously their
contact
traced through in the main through the
national system unless they were in a
high consequence setting so for example
if it was there would be some settings
that would be counted
children's men for example um so they
all the ones
that we've seen so far have been contact
traced through the national system
um the i don't get the data from that
directly and this is something that
we've been raising as an issue and that
is apparently going to be added to the
data sets we get
so i don't get that but a colleague of
mine in public health england did mia
ran through the data for me and she said
that actually the traffic copy it looked
like
um there was quite good engagement with
those young people
and actually i i would say that the
number of people we saw in that
particularly that 17 and 18 year old
age group some of them didn't give
all the contacts and when you started
looking through the whole set of it you
could piece together more stories from
different people being named in
different settings and so on
but actually what i think they've
probably done is done contact racing
themselves
uh and they've let each other know oh i
tested positive go for a test we've got
quite a few where we've got you know
three or four 18 year olds going at the
same time be tested and so on and you
think
and i the other thing is that at the
moment um obviously testing is for some
people who are symptomatic
i would not be at all surprised if some
of those young people
wanted a test and haven't said they've
got symptoms rather than actually having
symptoms
the third thing i'm looking at is
obviously as the data comes through i
will be looking because i now have the
postcode data etc
so i can look through and see who else
is living in the if anybody else tests
positive in those same households
and at the moment we're not seeing all
that many
parents or other siblings within those
households coming forward and testing
positive
but as i say it will be data that i
would expect be coming
through in the next few days if they are
getting ill
if other household members are becoming
ill i'll we'll be knowing about that
by the end of this week early next week
probably
okay something i'm very much keeping an
eye on camera
the isolation it is really hard but we
just have to keep putting that message
that the negative test results as well
if you're told to self-isolate that
means you even if if you're a contact
you must self-isolate
councillor john lamb uh thank you very
much chair and
actually colleagues uh our past and
and responses have been given uh to a
lot of the queries i also
uh have so i think i'd just like to very
briefly reinforce i think what
uh karen barkley was saying quite uh
forcibly and very well which is
around the messaging uh and i know
eleanor is of that
view also i'm sure there's lots of work
going on around
appropriateness of messaging making sure
it hits home
because to me this seems something
inevitable about a rise in the
numbers as the economy starts to open up
but it doesn't need to be
that way if uh you know sensible
precautions are
taken and everyone plays their fall
apart so i'm probably just reinforcing
what
uh uh karen was talking about cambodia
was talking about earlier
but i i do think maybe as a uh scrutiny
committee we might you know be able to
play our
sort of party if you like in in making
that sort of
recommendation uh in support of other
activity that's
going on uh to ensure that messaging
uh is through appropriate uh uh uh
media mediums uh and um you know gets to
the
gets to the real sort of uh points that
needs to be made particularly to younger
to younger people thank you very much
okay
before i bring in councillor blackburn
um
council barclay has um
could could eleanor respond to the
question about
self-isolation and residents returning
from spain
so i think that was a the other question
that he had i
apologize yes um yes of course i mean
we'll be we'll be working in line with
the national guidance on that
and so certainly from the council point
of view i think uh
the policy is being discussed i think um
jane or diane may be able to
fill in more of the details but i think
for people who
came back off you know who were on
holiday while
um when the quarantine was suddenly
announced i know that the council will
be supporting those people to stay at
home because obviously they do have to
stay at home and they must self-isolate
but what we would be doing is making
sure that no employees
willfully go now on holiday to spain and
then um
expect to be self-isolating
to manage that differently so absolutely
at the moment we will be
we are doing everything that is in line
with the government guidance and we will
be supporting those messages right if
you've been in spain
you must self-isolate for those two
weeks when you got back
thanks thanks uh councillor blackburn
okay um thank you mr chairman could i
ask elena
if you can comment um about the uh those
residents
who have been hospitalized in the past
or
are still being hospitalized due to the
severity
of the condition so we have not seen an
increase in the hospitalization rates
yet
um so hopefully that it would be early
days so hopefully that will continue
but um obviously there has been
increasing recognition
for that covid19 can be a very nasty
disease for some people and quite
unexpectedly unpleasant
um and with really bad symptoms and side
effects so again we've been working with
the ccg and with the lco and mft
to make sure that people who have been
badly affected are able to be supported
appropriately and have the
rehabilitation and so on that they need
yeah could i just comment as well um
my sitting room is opposite of park and
i've seen
quite a number of um teenagers
in large groups which is a normal thing
and i cannot see them not congregating
in their you know their peer groups um
you know especially as as the weeks go
on and on
um i don't see a way of them distancing
themselves from each other at all
i think you're right and i think all we
can do is try and encourage it
i think we need to be working with
parents um to encourage it we do know
that being out in the open air is safer
so i would rather that they were in a
park if they're in the large group than
in somebody's house in a large group
because that that will um help stop the
spread the other thing is i think we do
have to be saying to young people
actually you need to be thinking about
the impact on other
you know your friends with diabetes who
really can't be behaving in that way
because of the risks to them
and also the impact on people on your
grandparents so if you are going to be
doing that
you really do need to be thinking about
who else you mix with
and how you manage that because if
you've been out in the park
three days ago with all of your mates
and you've been you know
close to a big group of them please
don't go and visit your grandparents
you know where you can keep that
distance visit you know
go to their garden gate they can be in
the doorway you can talk to them but
really please we do need to protect
people and you need to be thinking about
if you are doing this
then there are some other things that
you can't do and we need we need parents
and grandparents to really think about
that as well
to support that message into young
people
okay counselor aidan williams
um thank you chad i just wanted to sort
of um
having listened to what other members
have said just
put on record that i think you know yes
it's concerning that there
is a rise in the number of positive
cases identified amongst the younger
population in trafford
but i do think it i don't want the
committee to be a or doom and gloom i
think it's worth reflecting i think
there's been incredible
buy-in um for my younger communities
in complying with the conditions of the
lockdown and you know it's been
difficult for everyone but
uh as the youngest member of the traffic
council i think if i look back to when i
was a teenager i know it would have just
sent me
up the wall having to spend all that
time uh stuck inside with my parents so
um
and and i think the flip side as well is
that you know
yes it's concerning that we're
identifying the cases but it's also a
good thing if younger people they're
coming forward and um
presenting at testing facilities if
they're if they're concerned about the
health status so i i really welcome that
um my my question uh actually
complements something that uh
council of blackburn just referred to
because i think where
i'd be really concerned it's not so much
if we've got um
we're identifying an increase in
transmission amongst healthier young
people
it's if we then see a further spread and
if we then saw an increase in hospital
presentation
and admissions and i was just wondering
if we could clarify the data that we do
receive
about hospital admissions because um you
know i've really welcomed the
the weekly dashboard that's been
circulated around elective members i
think it's
really reassuring to see all that data
especially a bit of an anxious person
like myself
but that that has been one thing that's
been missed i think from the dashboard
we've had great data about positive
tests numbered tests
and particularly about how it's
interacting with our care home sector
so i was just wondering you know um
yeah we can add that and we're not
seeing we're not seeing an increase in
hospitalizations at the moment michelle
will be able to give
more information um if you want but we
can we can absolutely add that we have
that data
um and we can add that green thank you
i hope you're not uh implying that some
of us
um can't remember our teenage years
[Music]
really really quickly and some of the
moments gone with the the nature of the
conversation but just to follow on from
councillor williams comments
i would absolutely want to echo the fact
that our young people
have been tremendous our young people
have done things like
create videos put out newsletters share
their personal stories
as a way of communicating with each
other
because there's nothing more powerful
than young people talking to young
people those boring old adults don't do
a very good job of it so i would
absolutely echo that
and i guess it was to follow up from
eleanor and councillor weston's
very earlier points about is is it
coincidence that these things happened
when the pubs reopened and we saw a
wider opening of schools
eleanor is absolutely right there has
been tremendous work from our public
health colleagues with all of our
schools and our head teachers and that
has been one of the biggest things that
has helped
be able to build confidence and enable a
greater number of pupils to
return to school and i know we've got it
later on on the agenda but
actually the planning and the
preparation in terms of that um
full opening in september we'll be able
to answer more fully on
i guess it's just that point that um
young people don't live in isolation do
they they do live within families and
some of those families do have younger
children as well as older adults and
grandparents
so i think it's right that we can keep
that collective view on
what does the total pattern look like um
but i would want to echo those words
that our young people have been
in the main incredibly responsible
incredibly responsive and incredibly
generous in terms of sharing some of
their personal stories
thank you for that phil um councillor
harding
thanks chair i think it was i also
wanted to
um reiterate what counselor williams had
just said then really is the mum of the
16 year old
who has struggled and terribly
throughout this
um you know not having contact with
friends and
life-changing decisions around gcses and
all of those things
you have your life mapped out at 16 so
they've needed to see other people
they've needed social contacts they
needed to be around people because
frankly it's you know the social anxiety
that has come from this
with a 24-hour news cycle as well uh you
know
it has been really um really upsetting
to see
so what i want to just stress really is
whatever messages we put out there we
mustn't demonize our young people
this isn't about a blame culture we
mustn't demonize young people
it's a bit about so what jill was saying
then and eleanor has said we do know
that
there are family units and potentially
if younger people
want to go and see their grandparents
some of the messaging that came out
about the masks if you wear this and you
wear this then we protect each other
is there a way of doing some kind of
messaging that allows younger people to
see that if they
are respectful around their social
distancing hand hygiene and so on
the impact on on older people is this
but we must do it in a way that doesn't
demonize young people that
and we celebrate the fact that they have
fought into this and it's had a
significant impact
on their lives yeah no okay
thanks for that
you wanted to come in thank you chair
and thank you let me come back in and i
didn't want my comments i hope it wasn't
my comments that spurred
counselor william council hardy to say
that because i actually live with three
20 year old children and i get my
impressions
and my views obviously from my own
experiences and
um basically and i don't wish to
demonize it
i totally support what's been said about
how wonderful our children have been but
i
just think that younger adults just
maybe need to be
reminded as we've already discussed
about you know the concerns because
from my perspective and my experience of
things
there is a kind of tendency to kind of
forget even for ourselves that this is
over and
clearly it isn't but absolutely 100
support our young people who have been
absolutely tremendous and cope with
something that's really really difficult
and obviously
has made life very difficult for
everybody so and i do hope it wasn't my
comments that precipitated that thank
you
i'd just like to add i think um you know
it is really important that people are
out and about in the summer
and we need everybody needs to be out
and about we our shielded population
need to be
out safely it's so important for
people's mental health and physical
health that they get some
exercise and so on i have a i'm
personally thinking you know the winter
is going to be long for a lot of people
especially with worries around flu and
so on and so forth so the more we can
do to make sure that everybody is in a
good as good
physical and mental health as possible
before the autumn
the better and that does involve people
going out and socializing and seeing
people
but it's just trying to make sure that
if people you know that we get those
messages about how to do it as safely as
possible
and that we get the message that it's
not over because i think that is the
message that lots of people had had
okay can i just can i just ask
a couple of questions one is about
um the areas that we've found
increases positive
people who you know
have been positive um
which areas are they and and what
what the
the other question which i think is
really important if
if and let's hope it doesn't happen that
we
have to trigger um you know extra
measures
what are the plans in relation to that
because you know i might
you know i think i think we hear
different messages in terms of
of how you deal with uh a spike in your
area
and and can we actually isolate
um you know certain areas within the
borough or would it
necessarily have to be the whole borough
that would would need to
take measured or different measures in
different areas so it's just really how
we
plan for that and hope that we never
actually have to do it absolutely and i
think um i think it will depend a lot on
what
what the cases are telling us and what
the demographics are like
so at the moment
the we have the most cases um over the
last three weeks we've had the most
cases
in the wa15 postcode area
the m41 postcode area and the m33
postcode
area relatively closely followed by the
m32 postcode area but
of the cases we've had over the last
three weeks or so 36 have been in wa15
34 and m41 34 and m33
21 input m32 11 in m16
3 and m31 9 in wa14 so
you know quite a big differences between
different areas but
quite spread um
as we find out more over this next week
about who's being tested and where they
live
and as i say i will be back in touch
with my phd colleagues to try and get
more about them from the contact tracing
data because that's where you get the
real insights
then we'll know a little bit more about
where we are seeing cases but the other
thing we've been doing is doing some
work with
our workplaces to make sure that the
workplaces are as cover secure as they
possibly can be
so that's not just the bars and
restaurants but that's places like the
bigger industries in trafford park and
so on
and learning from other areas quite
often places have done really well
at making sure the inside of their
buildings and the
work areas are really well managed but
the communal areas and shared spaces so
sometimes the lifts
very frequently and obviously this
completely appalls me you'll be
you'll you know me well enough the
smoking shelters
have been places where people have just
been congregating
similarly sometimes canteens and
changing areas
so we are doing work with our local
industry and local businesses to make
sure that they're as safe as possible to
stop any workplace
related spread um so
in terms of what we're planning for i
think it would it would very much depend
on
where we think the driver of the
um any outbreaks is coming from is it
from businesses is it from
um is it from the nighttime economy um
is it from
uh faith groups where where is it and
then what would we do in response to
that
and at the moment um we're not at that
point yet but those
you know those are the sorts of the
conversations that we will be having to
have
um and obviously that will that the
ultimate decision is
is with the chief executive um advised
by
a number of people including myself yeah
oh okay
thanks for that um and i know john
holden's
uh holden is going to have to leave the
meeting in a couple of minutes but
that's
fine um yeah there are no questions at
this moment in
time um oh wait a minute linda blackburn
is requesting council in the back
platform
thank you could i just ask is there any
difference
in the incubation periods of the disease
dependence on age um
i don't know the answer to that the
average at the median is fit
five days but i don't know that there's
any difference but we do know that
younger people are more likely to be
completely asymptomatic so
um and then so if you're completely
asymptomatic it's very hard to tell what
the incubation period of the disease is
because you'll only get
you know you you wouldn't you don't have
that cut off to
tell you that you've got the symptoms
from the exposure so unless you're doing
a lot of tests the whole sort of whole
population testing it would be quite
hard to get that up
but for symptomatic people it seems to
be about five days
as the median and anything between one
at the lower level
and two well 14 is the
outer limit really at the moment we
think um more like 12
with 14 being for to be safe but as i
say
because of the asymptomatic um spread is
quite
difficult to know what's happening with
with those people
okay um i can't see any other hands up
so
can i thank you for for taking all those
questions uh and clearly
you know you've had a busy time i think
over the last uh
well for a long long period of time but
particularly
as a spike has gone up a little bit um
you know and and the immediate contacts
that you've
you know you have to sort of do
um which is not easy and so
i'd just really like to thank you so
much for
coming along today and answering the
questions in the
manner that you have in a very open and
um honest uh and kind of way that we
we we actually understand so um you know
keep up the good
work eleanor and thank you so so much
for coming today thank you you're
welcome
um can we just move on now um
because within the health and adult
social care
um we we did
um we we've got diane eaton
and councillor joanne harding
you know the director and the executive
member
here um i don't know whether you've got
anything to report
to us um or you'd like to report
anything to us
yeah i don't know who's going to come in
first
yeah would you want me to want me to do
a short update
yeah just just an update really i think
i think it'd be
very helpful for us yeah okay thank you
uh counselor just by by way of update
obviously our
our services are starting to reopen so
things like
bay services and respite provision we
are starting to reopen
up however they are limited because of
the social distancing
so we are doing a review of what what
our offer and arrangements are going to
need to look like in the long term
we're also working very closely with mft
and with manchester around
um the second wave predictions and what
kind of service and
capacity modeling we need for the future
at the moment our services are coping
well we've got capacity in all of our
service provision
and from our residential nursing homes
our discharge for assessed beds
our support rapid discharge home care
services etc
and our intermediate care have all got
capacity to manage
need the hospital discharges have
increased
over the last three four weeks which is
normal activity now it is not covered
activity
and so people generally who who have
needed um
support and who are now getting back to
normal
and our social work activity is starting
to receive referrals increased back to
normal levels while safeguarding
referrals etc
and referrals domestic violence are um
increasing again as as we would have
expected and predicted
so um we're at a steady state i think
is where we are obviously anticipating
winter
we've got our winter plans being uh
prepared uh based on that capacity
modelling
[Music]
are there anybody
okay yeah we've got michelle
irvin here and really pleased to
to to see you from traffic ccg
um sorry i've raised my hand to ask a
question
oh i'm sorry right now but just to
finish what i was saying
um but um michelle's from trafford ccg
and um you want you know i think prepare
to
update it on the outpatient appointment
which i think will be
really useful but we'll we'll finish
this path
so sorry about that um right
counsellor valley winter stanley yeah
thanks chad it's just a it's a it's a
question around the rapid disclosure
range
hospital because all people i speak to
that and that has worked really well
that's been a real
a real model of the like install one of
the plans to keep that in place
um yeah you smiled going going forward
are there any plans to keep that in
place yes
um well it's been very it's very very
interesting because we've used some of
the providers that we use
in trafford anyway and we commissioned a
very um
intense piece of rapid discharge work
for the
four months um period that we've we've
managed
that contract is due to end in september
but we are remodeling so that our
uh current services around home care
starts to deliver
that kind of services as a permanent
offer
we will need to go out to procure that
properly um because it would be for a
longer period but we're remodeling our
home care anyway we've done
quite a lot of work over the last 12
months testing out different
models and the rapid discharge was
actually a model that was in test
and we escalated it and and accelerated
that very quickly
but it has been very successful and
we've had some really really good
results
um and outcomes from that so yes we are
building that into our long-term model
and it's good to have the feedback thank
you can i can i just respond to that as
well chair
really um um we i think we've always
been
quite innovative and progressively
trafford by way of thinking about
different ways that we can
you will know that historically we've
been an outlier in trafford for our
hospital discharges and delayed
transfers and so on so we've had
discharge to assess and so on so it's
been
really reassuring to see this model work
well but more importantly let's remember
it's about the person in the middle of
this the sooner we can get people
out of hospital back to some level of
independence with the right package of
care
around them or potentially going to a
discharge to assess
before they um then go on to a
residential setting
it's actually it's been it's been really
worked really well
and i'm keen for us to evaluate that and
take some lessons
learned from it but absolutely to
support what diane's saying it's the
model that we want to continue
because it's about the person at the
middle of this and making sure that
that we get them um the care that they
need at the right time and they're not
just stuck in hospital
excellent yeah that's great this is no
other
questions can i just uh ask michelle
just to speak about the outpatient's
appointments
thanks very much okay thank you chair
before i do that i just thought i might
give you um
um some figures in relation to an
earlier conversation you were having
around the impacts of covered in the
hospitals
so today we have 39
patients in patients in our mft
beds that's north central and south
um covered positive and six of those are
in intensive care
at the height of the pandemic we had 474
patients that were pulled
covered positive in our hospital beds so
just to say
that ellen is absolutely right we have
the lowest level we've had
since the pandemic started and we're not
seeing
any impacts um of the kind of recent
spikes in terms of hospital admissions
but we do look at it every day and we
can make sure it's added to your
dashboard i just thought you might be
interested
that's really really useful i think yeah
so in terms of output so for those of
you who don't know me my name's michelle
irvin and i'm the director of
performance and quality improvement
and i am actually employed by manchester
health and care commissioning but i have
a
joint role across manchester and
trafford as do my team
and i think that works really well
especially around the work that we do
with our providers
and in particular the acute trusts so
i thought i'm here today to talk about
patients but diane did email me earlier
this morning to say that at a later
meeting
you might be interested in me coming
back to talk about the um
restart of the elective program in our
hospitals
and i'm very happy to do so but in terms
of outpatients
um i've sent you some slides in advance
of the um
the meeting and i just thought i'd
summarize them
very quickly and then very happy to open
up to
any questions so um back when the
pandemic um first started there was a
national directive for
all providers to stop um routine
elective activity
so in manchester foundation trust they
cancelled
over 130 000 outpatient appointments
and that was patients that were away
seeing routine
first-hand follow-up appointments from
the months of april through to the end
of june
and on the back of that they set up a
sort of outpatient programme board
and it was very internal focused
initially looking at
cancelling the appointments risk
stratifying the patients to make sure
that those that were clinically urgent
could still be seen um and all the
logistics associated with that
but about six weeks ago um we agreed
that we would um
move that program to being just intern
not from just
internally focused to actually more of a
collaborative piece of work
so i am i joined the mft
outpatient recovery group i also
attend the mft strategic recovery group
which is about all their programmes of
work and i
attend that three times a week monday
wednesday friday and i attend their
outpatient recovery group
once a week on a wednesday so i am
really close to the work that they're
doing
um we've got strong clinical leadership
involved in the program as well so jane
edelson who's a medical director for mft
is also the director lead for the
outpatient recovery work
and we have the medical director from
trafford ccg mark
and the medical director for manchester
health and care commission manisha
absolutely stitched into the work one of
the things that i'm really keen that
that group does
is think about equality diversity and
inclusion
so in the context of 130 000 outpatient
appointments being
um cancelled and all of the evidence we
have through the pandemic around
inequalities and certain groups being
disadvantaged and inequalities widening
i'm really keen that that group looks at
recovery through not just a clinical
prioritization lens
but also an inclusion lens and we're
doing quite a lot of work with some
external organizations
to make sure that we are considering all
of those issues
there's also a national piece of work
that started around outpatients
improvement and the north west has been
asked to lead that and i'm now sitting
on the northwest programme
around outpatient recovery to make sure
that what we're doing
in gm what we're doing locally in terms
of trafford and manchester
is aligned to what the north west
expects of us and what is expected of us
nationally
so that's a really good connection and i
think that it's really important to say
that we had our first meeting of that
northwest
group about two weeks ago now and we did
um
a bit of a stock take against our action
plan and what came out of that group to
make sure there was nothing we're
missing
so i think that we feel as though we've
got a really good program of work around
it
so i've identified on slide three the
actual program of work
and all the priority areas that we're
really focusing on
and but as part of this slide deck what
i've also shown you is
the mountain we have to climb so there's
a slide which shows a graph
and that graph identifies the reduction
in activity that took place through the
months of
april and may and you can see that from
an outpatient perspective there was
about 60
000 less outpatient appoints so 60
percent less
outpatient appointments than had been
undertaken pre-covered
in the month of june and in the month of
july that's improved
hugely and we're now up to about 60
percent of our activity levels
and the plan is that between now and
september we get up to about 90 to 100
of the pre-culverd activity levels but
of course there's massive backlogs to
manage
through the months where there was very
limited activity taking place
slideshow 4 and talks about the program
in detail and it's identified in system
phases one two and three
we're currently in phase one moving to
phase two
and the real focus in phase one has been
around improving the digital offer
so advice and guidance to our gp's um
telephone appointments for our patients
and video appointments for our patients
phase two which is the phase that we're
going into now is about how we
collaborate much better around referrals
and making sure that we've got
the right referrals coming into the
right place and they're all clinically
triaged appropriately
at the point of receipt within
manchester foundation trust
and we're also testing out some work
with our gp colleagues around
looking at ways in which we can assess
whether
some patients that were referred a long
long time ago
as routine patients still absolutely
require those outpatient appointments
i've got some gps with special interests
working with the gynecologists
mary's testing out some joint clinics
with patients
just to have a kind of rapid review of
that original referral
with the patient on the telephone to
make sure that their condition
is still as it was um but i think that
what's really critical to say is that
within all of that performance has
deteriorated quite significantly locally
and nationally and we have lots more
patients waiting over 52 week weights
than we did and precovered we have lots
of patients waiting
over 18 weeks within those routine
pathways
that we didn't have and we also are not
delivering on our cancer standards
so the recovery program is kind of
two-pronged it's looking at different
ways
of managing activity going forward but
it's also saying
what's the best way we can actually
manage the backlog of patients
who have been cancelled during that
three-month period
so i think that's a bit of a
whistle-stop tour of the outpatient work
that's taking place
um i'm very happy to take any questions
but i think i just want to stress that
it's an
absolute priority of all of our provider
organizations
over the coming months to get the
services as diane just described in
terms of adult social care
back up to where they were within the
constraints that are in the system
yeah thanks very much for that
comprehensive
update i think it's really really
helpful
um there's a few people who want
um to ask question questions uh
counselor
doctor callum barkley and
um counselor quince stanley and
councillor
thompson have indicated they want to
speak so
uh karen it's thank you and
thank you to michelle for her verbal and
written report they were both um
really informative very detailed very
very interesting to read and very very
reassuring to learn that
our outpatient services are returning to
normal
but michelle can i just ask you that um
heaven forbid
our cases of covered increase and what
are the plans for protecting the
outpatient recovery um
service or program because obviously
that's something that could really knock
things off course again
thank you thank you yeah so
um i think that it's quite complicated
but on a very practical level what the
providers have been doing
is um reworking their estate
so that they have specific zones that
are covered free
so the outpatient environment has been
designated as one of those
green covered free environments
so hopefully that's protected um
for the face-to-face appointments also
the trust's plan is to move towards
around 60 to 70
digital so that telephone and
video offer is really going to be a big
part of
protecting the environment and
protecting activity
i guess the difficulty is that
one of the main reasons that activity
was cancelled during the first three
months
was to do with workforce and in
particular lots of clinicians were
repurposed so that they were covered
facing
and if we get ourselves in a situation
that we were in in april may
and june where we have hundreds of
patients in our hospitals
we may need to repurpose that clinical
time
to covered facing work and if that
happens
then clearly all of the things were put
into con
into place in terms of protecting this
date and developing virtual offers
um are no longer valid options because
if we haven't got the clinical staff
to actually manage the patients then
it's very difficult
so we're very hopeful that um one all
the measures have been put in place
prevent the spikes that um could happen
um the evidence so far is that
especially with the
the younger presentations they are not
being admitted to hospital in the way
that we've seen through the first three
months of it but it is our dilemma
and there's been lots of modelling
undertaken across all of our service
areas
to think what that might look through
but if we got ourselves in the same
position within three months ago
then um and we have to repurpose our
clinical staff
then it might not be difficult to
realize the plans we have in place
thank you um okay councillor barry gwen
stanley can i just say
that we've got 20 minutes left of the
meeting
and we have to finish uh at six so
can your questions be sure um
and clearly the answers need to be
fairly short
as well and i'm really sorry about that
i'll be very very happy for the item to
come after yeah barry
thank you thanks dave i'll be very brief
then just to say
uh michelle i think it's brilliant that
you're addressed
there's going to be a quality awareness
and trend there's going to be an
awareness of inequalities built into the
system when you start to restart things
because
one thing of this this pandemic has
thrown a massive spotlight on his
books inequalities in their in our
system particularly the protected
characteristic
but it's if you're just wondering if you
yet had an awareness of what
the the mechanism will look like that
will address that trade-off between
prioritizing people with a protected
characteristic while at the same time
addressing the
the clinical requirements because that
strikes me to be quite a difficult a
difficult trade-off to
to make yeah absolutely and myself and
manisha kumar the medical director from
manchester health and care commission
i've got a meeting with um
tally one of the medical directors at
mft to have exactly that conversation
because the principles for restart that
have been developed by mft are very
secondary care focused
and very focused on clinical
prioritization based on
referral information so we're having a
conversation to say
if we were to consider other dimensions
like protected characteristics
how might we weave that into it because
it's a very difficult balance to be
struck
when you've got limited capacity to deal
with those clinically urgent patients
and other patients might be sitting in
based on referral information
routine categories but may have
underlying health conditions
or may come from particular groups of
the population
that we know are at risk so i don't have
an answer to it but we have got a
meeting lined up to actually have the
conversation
thompson thank you
just a quick one can you just give us a
flavor
of a breakdown of the elected procedures
for
us and anyone who might be watching
sorry um could you just maybe expand on
and what you mean by that
what procedures have been put some you
know on the waiting list
kind of a breakdown of who what kind of
people
have been waiting so um
it's it's all specialties
and it's all um
clinically prioritized routine patients
so what the trust did when it cancelled
all of the outpatient appointments
it its clinicians looked at every single
referral and put them into four clinical
priorities
priority one where where it was life
deemed life threatening
um prior to two which was cancer and
urgent and priority three which was
routine
and through the covert periods priority
one patients have continued to have
their
outpatient appointments a significant
proportion of priority two and priority
three
but no patient who is clinically
prioritized routine
has had their outpatient appointments
during that time so it's all service
areas all types of patients
okay i don't see any other hands up
so uh can i thank you
so much for for coming today and uh you
know
i think the information that you've
given us is very very helpful indeed
and so thank you thank you
can we now move on to item eight which
is
schools and education and um
i i i don't know who's here now
it's um jill are you going to
i can take oh yeah okay
yeah i lost you there
can you be as brief as possible because
yeah
we you know we've got a window and then
if anybody wants to kind of ask any
questions afterwards
that's absolutely fine so obviously
schools have now closed for the summer
um prior to them closing um there were
around 7 000 children across trafford
who were in attendance at school
um and there's no expectation that the
schools will have an offer for
for children um over the summer but and
there are a number of providers
who um including some schools who are
offering a range of activities over the
summer
and the virtual school is facilitating
some summer school
for vulnerable children and obviously
the schools have been working really
hard on putting their plans together
um to welcome children back in september
and they've been reviewing their risk
assessments um
and we've been supporting them to do
that obviously that can be quite
challenging in some of the schools
and because of the space that's
available
to them um i think eleanor talked before
about
how public health have been supporting
schools and i think they've found that
incredibly valuable around kind of what
health and safety measures
to put in place and what to do if there
are any localized
outbreaks obviously we do know that
there's quite a lot of anxiety from
children
um and from parents as well about the
children returning to school
um and this obviously needs to be um a
key priority really
um as as children start to go back but
also they've been
um a lot of touch points actually
from the schools uh communication out to
um to to children and parents around
what to expect when their that their
children go
back to school there's been um some kind
of
interesting innovations around that i
know some schools have
put together kind of a virtual package
so that
um the the children and the parents can
see you know kind of how the one-way
system will work and all of those sorts
of things
and there has been a lot of focus
obviously around um
catch up initially what that catch up
is is going to to kind of involve
will actually be around around that
support
and around that kind of making sure that
people um
do feel supported in going back to
school so that they can
be in that place where they're able to
start learning and that can't be
underestimated um because of that kind
of sense of anxiety
really um so
um there are also
that there are a number of of kind of um
of
sort of support mechanisms around the
the emotional
um and social aspects of the return to
work but there are some practical
um steps being put in place as well
really
around um where we think there might be
specific
areas of focus there's a um there's a
program a collaborative program that's
been led by
um ashton on mersey um which is
promoting projects
um around maths because this may be
obviously one area
where we know that um that children
might need
some specific support um in terms of the
funding
um aspect so um the
the catch-up funding is not going to be
received um until the
autumn um and apparently it will be
provided in
three uh tranches it will go to schools
directly
um and it equates to approximately you
know it equates to
yeah around 80 pounds per pupil
and there is some very clear criteria
and what it
it can be used for um and
and the focus um is on tuition for
um pupils we are doing some work with
um tfgm um to baseline
what kind of public transport is going
to be needed this is a specific
um issue to trafford obviously all
children need to
to kind of travel to school but in
trafford as eleanor said earlier on
actually
we know that um that we have children
that travel
right the way across the borough and
that public transport
um system has been massively impacted by
covid
so we are working with tfgm um because
this is an
area obviously of of concern for us and
we're also working
um with um to
well we've sent our survey actually to
um
to in respect of our send pupils
uh to try and understand what the demand
will be there because there has been
again some
some impact around um transport
to to schools and the there's so much
going on in the service but i am
incredibly conscious of time so i'm kind
of
gonna gonna pause there in in terms of
the schools and obviously take any
questions but
before i do that i was just going to
hand over and see if there was anything
that
jill wanted to kind of either add about
schools or also around
kind of more broadly the search planning
that we're doing
in um children's services is there
anything that you wanted to add
jail that's all you have to be very
brief i was just gonna say i'm really
pleased it's
quick in terms of time because i'm about
to be timed out on my pulse
um connection because i've been online
so long today
and i think um as councillor heinz has
said there is a massive amount of going
going on the week before last i had the
privilege to go into one of our schools
and actually meet with some of our young
people and meet with some of the staff
there
and i think i know we've got members
that
are school governors who have been in
school throughout that period and i
think unless you've actually done that
you can't quite envisage what that looks
like and what that means in terms of
that learning
experience so as um councillor hines has
said
the initial two weeks our schools have
been really really clear that they
just need to assimilate children back
into school they need them to give the
opportunity to familiarize themselves
that does not mean to be they will not
be structured learning
but actually as we know that actually
creating the environment for
pupils to be able to learn has to be
right so that is going to be a key focus
and there are a number of initiatives a
number of tools that have been
um promoted we've worked really closely
with our schools
one of the bits that we haven't
necessarily drawn out and i'm not sure
if everybody knows about it earlier on
the way
from elizabeth stanley there were
questions about bme
populations not just in terms of
children with additional needs but more
broadly
we've got a really exciting interesting
piece of work where believe it or not
we've invited an ofsted inspector to
come and do some work with us
and one of their first bits has been
about providing tool kits for schools
generally
but doing a significant engagement piece
around bme
needs and councillor carter hosted an
event with kate green last
friday in terms of engagement with the
bme community
so just to be absolutely clear
we are cited on that issue we haven't
been presumptuous to know that we know
all of the answers and we are doing a
significant
engagement piece around that as kath
says
happy to take any questions just to
clarify
in terms of the reason for sending the
send survey out
to our parents carers and
our schools of children with additional
needs and
that is because at this moment in time
we've had low numbers of children with
additional needs going to school
for a whole host of reasons which i'm
sure you can imagine
but equally our passenger assistants
tend to be older adults
a number of whom have health needs and
just to give you some idea of what that
challenge looks like
we currently only have 20 27
of our passing passenger assistance
available to work so we're needing to
understand
what the demand looks like so as we can
put in place the right
um supports we are promoting the use of
personalized budgets and we are
promoting the use of parents carers
having
choice about how um what would feel the
best way for them to be able to support
their children and young people to get
to school
thanks very much for that um and
i'm really sorry about the time but uh
we we've not got time for
questions so if there's any questions
from members i think we need to
um we will need to get them in writing
uh to to capital or jill
um so um we
will now move on to and can i thank you
so much for
coming both both of you um you know it
it's been a long
two hours and uh you know your
involvement
have been um you know really well
received by everybody so
thank you so much um item nine
the the work program um
you know there is a report there about
that but i know that
uh general dean carlson
wants to speak so
i'll be very brief it's just yet another
appeal for after transport to be
discussed i have raised it before
obviously it's been in the news it's
getting bigger and bigger it's directly
covered related we know that we need
people as fit and healthy as we can and
low levels of pollution across this
winter i really would like to see it in
there in the september meeting if we
could
yeah we'll definitely get it in the
september meeting
yeah without any doubt yeah and
um yeah it'd be worth reminding me
but but i think alex will we will um
you know make a note of that so so that
we don't forget to
so yeah thanks can we just
note that work program and we're going
to item 10
items for future meetings um there is
an agenda panel meeting tomorrow but we
we are going to hold the the meeting
in august on the 19th of
uh of of august uh where
mainly we we we did sort of identify
that we needed to
look at uh finance the updated on on on
the finance
and and obviously we've got the um
the the mental health service as well
um yeah yeah karen
thank you chad sorry really really quick
uh just for our work program please
could we look
quite urgently uh maybe for our next
meeting or if not the one after
about the current provision for homeless
residents in the borough
especially giving the fact that there's
some end of summer is approaching and
i'm really concerned about
their care and and i think their
important group of residents we need to
look after them and
could we perhaps put that on our work
program thank you yeah i mean we
we we are meeting as a panel tomorrow
as i understand so raise it there karen
that'd be fine yeah
yeah all right okay um well that
actually concludes the meeting
uh so can i thank you all uh for your
patience and your
involvement and the questions uh
really appreciated and uh and thank the
officers as well
um and the executive members um
we're really grateful for all the work
that everybody is doing
so thank you very much and uh
and i won't say what i usually say have
a safe journey home
just flick off
bye bye everybody bye